what's up party people it's honest
trailer commentaries the show where we
talk about our show that talks about
other shows hopefully you watched the
show that we're about to talk about
before you watch this show if not hit
pause go watch that show come back watch
us talk about the show or some of you
just like to watch this show without
having seen the show that we're about to
talk about and that's cool too
i'm joe dan lon danielle hey knows if
you watched us join you this morning you
know the Spencer J Gilbert is done with
his responsibilities as a father and his
return to screen junkies but uh he
didn't see more legends I think you mean
yesterday morning Joe true oh yeah Oh
[Laughter]
yeah Spencer came yesterday and maybe
this morning I don't know because I
can't remember off the top of my head I
think our same shorts ruin it because
they do track charting ensembles there's
the last paternity benefit was not
having to watch more although I have a
baby I I sent him a text while watching
this movie and I said I think you only
had a child to avoid watching mortal
engines and he said is that the thing
were the cities are tanks now I watched
the Higgs amazing was this movie amazing
I leave it to the table no it was a lot
of movies um I you know I love silly and
this is big and silly and
incomprehensible and that is everything
I love I also wanted to punch this movie
in the face understood yes I like this
movie I recognize that it has a pretty
major problem which is that you don't
get to know or care about anyone who's
in it which usually would be the sort of
the he'll be like that's not good
but the the fact that the ambition and
the scale is so huge and they're leaving
it all out there and it's not holding
anything back like I begrudgingly came
to admire what they were trying to take
pure audacity it is it is throwing
everything at the wall it is not holding
anything back and the thing that a lot
of the movies that we watch not even
just for the show a lot of 2018-2019
movies you feel like they're they're
trying to set you up on it it's gonna be
a shared universe it's gonna be a
franchise we're doing all of this work
to kind of set the stage for more
adventures not this move you know these
like it put the whole series in one
movie dump a dump truck worth of every
story element we can think of in this
one movie and like I like that it's it's
crazy it's bananas it's not emotionally
satisfying but I was writing the honest
trailer for this movie in my head while
watching the movie which is ironic
because then I went on vacation last
week and didn't really help
was the act of watching these thinking
about how you would make fun of this
about 30 minutes then I was just like
okay we have to we I pushed hard for us
to do this movie because this is a movie
much like Robin Hood
just like we can't live in a world where
we haven't done the obvious move I agree
and I know a lot of people you're not
doing you're doing this this week and
it's like yes sometimes honest trailers
has to get back to its roots and just do
something dumb
whether or not it's attached to
something on the schedule or not well I
have nothing productive to say about
bumble bee I don't I have nothing and
funny or witty yeah I really really
don't so I it's much more appealing to
find a movie where there is something
fun yeah you're doing by the public has
to demand that we do movies that they
love right I get that that you want to
see like more a celebration of stuff
that you love but those are a lot harder
guys and it's they're better yeah this
is way better than the trailer we make
for bumble yeah yeah let's do a quick
preview of what the bumble bee trailer
would have been then we'll jump into
this geez get ready for nostalgia all
players oh look at this cute face but
why do they look so different than they
look in 10 or 15 years other movies were
bad but this one's good it's like we do
a lot we have to do a lot of movies that
we like don't have as big a take on
because they're big movies we need to
stay in business but I think sometimes
we have a chance to sometimes maybe skip
a quote unquote bigger one yeah might do
something like this my only regret going
into this trailer is that we very
recently already used the this movie as
completely overwhelming take with
Aquaman yes
had I known I know I would have I would
have adjusted and saved it for this but
I said I think that's a trend that we're
gonna start these event movies are just
getting bigger and bigger and longer and
dumber and
I think that's a take that's gonna go
like endgame will be a very chill
character piece yeah let's watch this
trailer starring this trailer from Peter
Jackson the visionary director of Lord
of the Rings comes a film ten years in
the making because he shunted it off to
his storyboard an effects guy to make
the Hobbit well that's one more thing I
can blame on The Hobbit movies mortal
engines welcome to a post apocalypse
earth a world that still seems pretty
okay looking nevertheless you better be
this force to fight over limited
resources by using tons of resources
it's very this whole post-apocalyptic
world is very confusing because they
tell you basically all of civilization
was wiped out in this one moment mm-hmm
but they have more technology than we
have today so it's not post it's like
it's like better than it was really
different technology because like cell
phones are in a glass case and people
don't know what minions are but yes they
can also build cyborgs dead people yeah
at some point bring the dead back to
life they can build these flying cities
and flying machines they can put weapons
that are more like this is a more
technologically advanced society than
ours at some point after the apocalypse
Bioshock came true yeah yeah it's like
it's like everything reverted back to
like the the Industrial Revolution rise
of steam power and then started going
forward again but went way further than
we are today
yes yeah so it's like the steam future
yes yeah post steam modernism steam on
massive mobile cities that devour
smaller mobile cities the hair wing
of hungry German will oppose except for
the humans that live in sky cities or in
mobile home parks or in just normal
cities which will make you wonder why
parts of humanity have decided to live
on massive mobile cities that consume
smaller mobile cities in a harrowing
game of Hungry Hungry Hippos the Earth's
crust gets shattered into a thousand
pieces it is threatened by an ancient
weapon the only thing standing in its
way
are these extremely attractive people
also these extremely attractive people
whose names you won't remember except
for Hester because they're Undead cyborg
dad won't stop shouting it
I've been yelling Hester all week and my
wife is psycho
I didn't know anything about any of this
going into the movie that was it and
when they introduced the undead cyborg
dad I'm like okay technology right and
what is this doing in the story I'm like
okay so this is the big bad
okay sure and then there's like twenty
to thirty minutes of the movie is about
him pursuing a Hester and then a and
then he dies as when they just keep
going on with the rest of what they were
it was so obvious and it's why I don't
envy anyone that has to adapt a popular
book books yeah you could tell this was
a character who worked in the book who
had no business being in the movie
adaptation and yet they knew that if
they didn't include him the people that
read the book would be so upset so they
put him in and I to to my eyes at least
he really had no bearing a part of me
does imagine it like it might have
really appealed you Peter Jackson who
likes zombies and creepy horror elements
like he might have really felt strong
about I want to keep this element in
this story but you gotta do more to like
really integrate it into the story this
is it comes totally out of left field he
sort of comes and interrupts the movie
and yeah I I feel like there are two
ways where it could have been like okay
I could be the thing one is if you keep
it he's the undead he's in constant
pursuit of Hester or whatever you lose
all the stuff about Hugo Weaving setting
them free and loosing him on cuz that
stuff was dumb it doesn't make it maybe
you just have this like strange question
mark element like what is this thing
where is it going why is it making
people up and going faster and I'm like
flinging them you know like what he's
like this weird chaotic element what's
he
be maybe that works but like like you
say about adapting a book it because
later they just will hit it in the
trailer if they're just gonna do Star
Wars anyway maybe undead cyborgs dad
just needs to be her c-3po but they have
a weird relationship because he actively
wants to kill her and make her a robot
and and that's a weird relate you know
maybe we just sit with that role really
in the movie you know I'm like maybe
maybe that's interesting if he's just
there and she's like yeah he's my
adopted dad he wants he wants to kill me
but for my own good and everyone's like
okay I'm sure in the book there are
there is plenty of reasons why this
character was a beloved and be made
sense I'm sure I'm not attacking that
and I just mean in this movie yeah no no
I shouldn't need I shouldn't even index
I shouldn't have done a back and read
the book like it the movie is the movie
and the movie has to work on its own
it's it's the first book from a series
of there are four books in the mortal
engine series they go do they get less
mortal as the because there's four books
in the main series and now the author's
going back and doing prequels that are
set between the destruction of
civilization and immortal and so was
filling the car taxi right so I feel
that probably is what it is but I feel
like maybe they had to introduce this
idea of resurrected men for later
adventures where it'll tie in more but
we're obviously never gonna get to see
the popularity of this film those three
are never gonna get me it'll just remain
a question mark for all time like why
did the zombie dad have to be and of
course if you don't want to read the
books you can always go to the mortal
engines Wikia Howard my fandom they'll
take all the professional bad person
Hugo Weaving in a special-effects field
race wait did I just say undead cyborg
dad
even there it's the intro the age of the
great predator cities there some movie
is ridiculous pause pause pause what
rank right so a props to John for his
spot-on Shrike impression yeah who knew
why did the undead cyborg dead nary at
the beginning of them like itch that
should have been the main guy right that
would have been a story weaving weaving
he's the historian and he's driving the
story in the beginning warts Peter
Jackson it's a P well it's a it's a
wingnut film just have Galadriel do it I
don't care but did did that opening
narration do anything to help us
understand the world as we came into it
easier to Center he's speaking about his
Kurt like the age in which he lives he's
dead and has no memory anyway how does
he even know this is the age of the
president cities what context is he he's
in our world
well hey long look at this story he
would be narrating to us what's the
context
I don't oh man I well if you want a
little behind the scenes look at how the
sausage was made in the original cut of
this it was my supreme wish that
everything he says goes in that run and
it was a matter of a minute long every
line of dialogue that Shrike speaks and
film is in that runs about a minute and
I I loved it and we came to a compromise
where it's just the screaming you know
what we're better off for it because I
was wrong I was wrong I admit maybe just
a solid minute-and-a-half
obviously we should probably upload that
separately as an agenda because it is
hilarious
I got maybe not perfect for the honest
trailer but very funny I was not here
last week so the first time I saw
anything of this was the first cut of
the movie and about 90 seconds into the
Shrike dialog run I'm like did the
others fall asleep on me running a
little late on this draft so Kevin was
like what can I work on and I was like
we're gonna we're gonna compare it to
Star Wars and we're gonna make fun of
strike a lot do those things okay
and I think we found a good spot all the
screaming it works yeah let's go Nick
Ulis
gear up for a visual feast of incredible
art design and intricate detailed
concepts then choke on an entire series
worth of these things all crammed into
one movie you're just too skivvy from
the lower tiers
if those dim-witted spanner heads
features the bins again you'll be back
to cleaning the box what they call it
southies scams and attraction make up
shank whoa nothing can stand in the face
of this of the battle hammers of
Archangel not the howitzers and Friends
of snack not even the guns of the
antique tracks honest there's there's
something to be said and I was thinking
about this a lot watching this cuz
actually these accidents tweeted this
and I was like man yeah this is a make
sure you follow Zak on Twitter because
he's just got some cool stuff to say but
he was talking about just sprinkling
color into your dialogue statistics to
build your world and Star Wars does it
so well serve its father and the Clone
Wars moving on okay now I know you're a
vet my dad was a vet and there was a
thing called the Clone Wars cool the
emperor has dissolved the Imperial
Senate blah blah blah okay now I know
there's an Imperial Senate and I know
that the Emperor is a badass cuz he
dissolved them okay got it got it got it
got it got it yeah every this movie also
could have been like his last speech
there is just naming things it's like
okay now I know that there are other
super weapons maybe and he's so cocky he
thinks Easter but there's so
each other stuff scabs get some of that
is set up earlier in the movie but it's
the it's the idea of like it's just a
constant stream of just having this jump
and then recall and re reference it's
too much I mean every line of dialogue
in the movie practically is like they
took out all the nouns and replace them
with fantasy nouns and like too much you
got a you had to be careful and
judicious a little bit of that is
world-building it's like you know leia
calling hana nerf-herder and like oh
there's an animal called the nerve or
got it where it's like we didn't one of
the lines that I pulled for their
mothers that we didn't end up using was
like Oh 50 quirks for a soggy dollop
like that it's like well no I don't know
what you're talking about
what's your work what's a soggy dollop
did you always think the nerf-herder was
an animal I mean I thought that the
animal was a nerf I just make sure that
I wasn't dealing with like there's the
steps that a nerf herder is like that
dog and I was thinking like nerd
nerf would be the animal the nerf herder
would be one can herds not playing
gotcha
I just want to make sure that I've not
been living in my own pocket University
where where there's an animal called a
nerf herder yeah nerve hurt okay good
herder of nerf I almost I almost looked
into the abyss there first is the
company nerf named after the animal
maybe one wouldn't surprise me it's it's
nerve for nothing I don't know too much
too much words in this it's constantly
to the point where it becomes ridiculous
so shoveling more into a furnace like
the predator City yes we don't learn
anything from it because it's all
nonsense like what our southeast scabs
like why still there no yeah exactly
well let's keep going this bit rushes
past all the cool stuff you'll actually
want to see an explorer so they can just
do Star Wars yes
I'll pour him
[Music]
you guys are missing as the father
revealed no mother never told you you
already knew yep really set myself up
for that one so put on your fanciest
waistcoat and top that off with your
most ridiculous hat for an ambitious
project that made sure to do every
dystopian earth trope all of the
steampunk things and as much social
commentary as possible so that is the
part of the movie that makes me want to
punch it in the face oh really
just I get doing all the social
commentary but I was telling I was
telling Jo because this movie spent so
much time where there were just people
staring and it's they might as well be
Stern directly in the camera if they're
so smart and they're smart enough to
make those hand screens how could they
have not protected this earth and like
it's like someone's looking into the
camera up off the style and that was the
part that bugged me I told Jo I was like
if this movie was a real person it would
be constantly telling you that it's not
on social media Facebook actually I'm
vegan of movies yes yeah yeah there's a
whole bunch of it it's pretty non-stop
there is so much of the because I mean
obviously like nuclear war and a big
it's sort of an anti-war screed by the
end and there there's so much of just
like a single cat character looking at
camera like why can't people just work
out their differences without fighting
with says a person sitting on top of a
giant city that eats other city get on
board I'm sorry yep you're right let's
go smug right altogether but for God to
tell a story you can follow with
characters you actually care about so
you probably forgot to see it man now
we're never gonna find out at the
Shangri knees and attraction as a
municipal Dharma's can coexist or what
any of those words even mean starring
in my knee danger do you want to know
how I got these scars flower of London
Sky Captain and the World Taekwondo
previously on The Walking Dead London
crawling people falling I guess this is
when you get a production designer -
director movies like it's got 18 levels
it's very dynamic action yes it kicks
acts like there's a lot of really cool
spectacle in it over yeah if there was
any shred of the story to the movie that
is party man offense the police that we
regard penny boy who was my father's
name
who call me you Nimrod never ever heard
pause because I know everyone's gonna
think that one was my oh the commenters
okay okay I reference model combat
Scorpion and sub-zero I've come up and
the writers especially I wanted to make
sure that credit went alright hope he is
just good at making things really
why does everyone in the post apocalypse
so dang pretty where my pasty
subterranean incest cannon fodder ad I
wanted a
what anomaly dies any chance to
reference fury road and I get into it
well a great example of world building
that's unobtrusive you get a tote you
you're very clear on what Mad Max is
world is like bullet town got it there's
not a lot of like let's stand around and
talk about gas town that's my guess yeah
those gas town quirks worth a pump isn't
that complicated either you don't need
to make it so taking a truck to go to
the bullet farm hey wait a minute
someone took the thing off course on the
way to bullet town got it okay following
but it's all choice to make it simple
like that they could have explained
everybody's - yeah like what what uh you
know what's going on in immortan joe's I
know they just don't which was nice yeah
I appreciate it they didn't have to
explain all this to me either I could
you could have spent a little more time
with Hester they could eat sweet Hess
congratulate Hugo Weaving in London or
evil
it took me if it was only the second
time through the movie that I recognized
that don't worry longer the Lord
Commander of London we supplants is bail
on Gretchen will do you know hey JT do
we have deleted scenes storing Scarface
negasonic teenage warhead yeah what
Stella's posh girls are all mine Dante
chic Avant good job dammit Beavis yeah
we were just worried that people don't
know his name's Tom that's weird yeah
it's the joke that we just called it
mortal engines no I don't know what that
is I don't know is there word of that
yeah okay that wasn't one of the we had
two other fake names but Robert we
didn't tell Robert to make a graphic
that she says more
make it your own I don't think we did
yeah yeah this is one of those ones
where it was like let's just let's just
group together some clips and because if
we really get in the weeds of like this
here's the funny things about this
character it's like no one cares like no
one knows no one knows who they are I
watched the movie twice and I don't know
these characters yeah the book readers
know outside of it cuz honestly we're
not worthy is what was one of my
favorite jokes on the page but it was
just like 90% sure what I said that to
you you went I hate you so much
I did I did it was a good joke yeah
that's that's more to legend you guys or
should I say Jamie's question yeah I
have a theory on this but I'm not sure
why why is it called mortal engines the
cities all have engines but are they
they're mortal because it sounds cool
is it and I bet there's something refer
to the engine that's inside of us I mean
like they were there more like it's all
along because in the beginning you think
it's gonna make sense cuz they're like
we have to keep feeding the engine or
London stops so it's like oh it could it
is immortal and just going to be it's
gonna die but then that's not the movie
has nothing to do with that yeah yeah
cuz I started figure if that's a
metaphor or not because other cities
like the little smaller cities they do
get eaten so I guess that's the
mortality of the city yes imagine city
yeah as London comes but the city's an
engine this is Shrike a mortal engine
maybe that is it
I like that Shrike had nothing to do
with the third ass nothing really
nothing to do with the move no it's
literally just like walks into scenes
that are the only thing he is there
revealed that those two kids fell in
love yes that's his big love now go okay
bye you guys stay tuned right here next
week for for another episode of honest
trailers mortal engine together we're
just yeah that's the twist we're doing
mortal engines again I hope I hope the
fragile egos can survive next week's
trailer we shall see see you guys next
week
[Music]